streams of lava have been spurting from
new fishers which have opened up
at a volcano in iceland that began
erupting last month
i'm joined by professor magnus
goodmanson a geophysicist at the
university
of iceland good to see you this morning
look what are we seeing here
in terms of of this volcanic activity
well we are seeing uh actually a
quite a small eruption this is uh
one of the smallest yet but how big it
will be in the end
is anyone's guess because this is
what's called uh it's very coming from
deep
this magma is what's called very
primitive
coming right from the mantle of the
earth and
in there are cases when eruption like
this can go on
for long but this is
placed nearer to
the population centers of iceland it is
30 kilometers from reykjavik
it's close to some town or 10 kilometers
from the town
on the south coast so what volcanic
activity in this area
is much closer to most of us than most
of the volcanic
activity in iceland but this is still
rather
uh and and probably will stay
small and what should we say manageable
well we're looking at pictures as you
talk of people getting
very close up to some lava flows i mean
personally i can see the interest
in this i'd love to see something like
this up close
and personal but how are there concerns
being raised about just
how many sort of tourists and visitors
this is now attracting
well that is the main effort uh i mean
there's a major uh
i pray operation ongoing uh
trying to secure the security
of people that go into the area
uh there is uh there are dozens of
rescue group people uh
present and it's organized and and by
the
local police and civil protection and
there are and it's all meant to
try to secure that nobody is harmed but
there is an enormous interest in this
this is spectacularly beautiful
and if people do things in the right way
there isn't much danger the problem is
if you go too close
if you go under a wall of of of larvae
it may collapse
there can be gas in in pockets and and
you can see the gas from the
from the rising from the plumes this is
uh
from the from the craters this is uh
mostly sulfur
and this simply is there are dangers but
this is being managed with quite a lot
of effort
uh and um but there is a
strong tradition in iceland that people
want to go and see a volcanic eruption
if at all possible and
and that is how this is handled yeah
i don't bla i don't blame them professor
i really don't
but how much danger is in terms of this
level of activity
could this escalate are we looking at a
more serious eruption at any point in
the near future
one can never be sure but the
indications are that this will go on
probably in a similar manner
we have no idea for how long it can go
on for
weeks months and if we look at the
geological past then we have events in
iceland that have probably gone on for
decades
we are not really expecting that but
nature
we don't know what nature is actually
going to do but this has quite some
similarities to the volcanic activity
that is
very common on hawaii well professor
goodman said it's good to talk to you
this morning thank you very much indeed
that is something i would very much like
to see
i have to tell you